le corps de monsieur félix gaillard et
celui de son ami ont été retrouvés ce
matin au large de l'île jersey les deux
autres passagères vous le savez ont été
trouvés noyer également morte
d'épuisement et de froid hier après midi
une partie de l'épave du yacht a été
localisée ce matin aussi une épaves
calcinées ce qui confirme l'hypothèse
d'une explosion à bord suivie d'un
incendie
je vous rappelle que le yacht de
monsieur philippe billard lamari grillon
étaient portés disparus entre jersey et
binic depuis jeudi dernier
il était 8h30 en effet jeudi matin
lorsque le yacht de monsieur félix
gaillard la mare grillon quittent l'île
anglo normande de jersey à destination
de bign la mer est assez forte mais elle
ne présente pas semble-t-il un réel
danger pour l'ancien président du
conseil et ses trois passagers reconnu
par tous comme d'excellents pas
d'inquiétude cependant commence à se
faire sentir à la villa ker lolette
résidence estivale de monsieur gaillard
au fur et à mesure que les heures
passent
alerté par madame gaillard le sémaphore
de saint-quay-portrieux déclenché dans
la matinée de vendredi un important
dispositif de recherche est très vite la
confirmation du naufrage parviennent aux
autorités la nuit dernière un pêcheur
retrouve pas des minquiers le canot de
sauvetage
un peu plus tard ce sont les corps des
deux passagères madame de la brosse et
mademoiselle dumont qui sont repêchés ce
matin une vedette des douanes repère les
débris calcinés de la mairie grillons et
puis en fin de matinée vers 11h30 la
découverte des corps de monsieur félix
gaillard et dominique cyrot taux met un
point final aux recherches
l'émotion la peine et vivent bien sûr
dans l'entourage de monsieur félix
gaillard mais aussi dans les milieux
dans tous les milieux politiques
français car félix gaillard député de la
charente est un personnage politique de
tout premier plan au sein de son parti
le parti radical mais aussi au niveau
des affaires françaises des affaires
publiques la république puisqu'il était
président du conseil il fut président du
conseil
en 1957 il avait alors 37 ans félix
gaillard qui avait épousé la veuve de
raymond patenôtre avait un fils et trois
filles
vous le voyez ici chez lui dans sa
propriété de barbezieux en charente il
en était le député depuis 1946 ministre
à 28 ans président du conseil à 36
c'était le type même de l'homme brillant
avant dernier président du conseil de la
quatrième république
il prépare par ces mesures financières
le redressement de 1958
mais il bute sur le problème algérien
président du parti radical de 58 à 61 il
soutient l'action du général de gaulle
nous demandons que soit ton poignet au
delà des sanctions nécessaires tous les
moyens propres au rétablissement de
l'unité entre la nation et son armée que
nous refusons à confondre a dans son
ensemble avec la faction d'activistes
qui a tenté de la débrouille mais en
1962 il entre dans l'opposition dans
l'opposition modérée
il participe par exemple à la tentative
de gaston defferre regrouper le centre
et la gauche non communiste au sein
d'une grande fédération
récemment pourtant il avait amorcé un
rapprochement avec la majorité en
préconisant une conjonction des
réformateurs
monsieur chaban delmas était un de ses
plus vieux amis
oui et déjà les premières réactions à ce
drame nous sont parvenues dont celle
précisément de monsieur chaban delmas
qui est on vient de vous dire un ami
personnel de monsieur félix gaillard ce
matin monsieur jacques chaban delmas est
en visite officielle à bordeaux
apprenait la nouvelle mais ne voulait
pas et ne pouvait pas encore à cette
heure croire à la disparition de son ami
je vous hais la disparition moi je me
refuse à je me refuse à l'admettre et
et je persiste à espérer que peut-être
toute espérance
une et par free n'est pas croyable fini
une chose pareille arrive est un homme
de cette de cette qualité et qui c'est
vrai a toujours été mon ami et notamment
a commencé à l'être à des moments
pendant la guerre ou dans la résistance
il avait fait preuve d'un courage
vraiment vraiment joyeux croyez moi j'ai
donné des ordres pour qu on ratisse
littéralement la mer mais vraiment moi
je nuis je ne peux pas l'admettre
cette disparition c'était en fin de
matinée comme on a retrouvé le corps de
monsieur félix gaillard à 20 heures jean
pierre elkabbach etienne mougeotte
retraceront pour vous à l'aide d'autres
documents et témoignages
la carrière de monsieur félix gaillard
cela dit bien il faut quand même
remarquer que ce drame est un drame de
vacances il y aura bientôt près d'un
millions de plaisanciers sur toutes les
côtes et bon nombre d'entre eux sont des
marins beaucoup moins aguerris que ne
l'était monsieur félix gaillard qui
était considéré comme un excellent ski
alors eh bien la fatalité bien sûr mais
peut-être aussi il semblerait un manque
de précautions dans ce cas dans le
maniement d'un appareil à gaz butane les
vacances maintenant est bien le grand
rush des vacances et bien commencé sur
les routes avec quinze jours d'avancé
grâce à ce pont providentiel du 14
juillet une nouvelle fois dans les
grandes villes les automobilistes ont
préféré partir la nuit et tous en même
temps et ce matin par exemple à 6 heures
il y avait plus de deux mille voitures
au péage de fleury sur l'autoroute du
sud donc sur la grande voie des vacances
pour les parisiens alors je suis en
direct en ce moment avec le commandant
pépin au centre routier de la
gendarmerie droit l'issue bois
commandant comment a t'on assisté
comment a t'on comment s'est passé cette
nuit et ce matin donc à votre pc
et peut-on dire que il s'agit là du
grand départ en vacances des parisiens
avec quinze jours d'avancé qu'il faut
faire d'abord une première remarque pour
bien situer le problème c'est en effet
le plus gros départs que nous ayons
enregistré depuis le début de cette
année 1970 les comptages sont formels le
trafic est de 15% supérieur à celui de
1969 à la même époque
ce trafic comprend évidemment une grosse
proportion de vacanciers
qui s'ajoutent aux départs en week-end
très lent donc particulièrement
favorable à une évasion massive
il a été très soutenue tout au long de
la nuit sur tous les grands axes mais
cependant les premières difficultés ne
sont apparus que vers 6 heures
outre la région parisienne vous n'existe
pas ou peu de solutions de rechange
on a observé de très grosses difficultés
sur tous les axes en direction du
sud-est du sud ouest de la bretagne en
normandie et choses exceptionnelles je
dirais vers le nord et vers l'est
mais comment dont je m'excuse de vous
couper mais maintenant que les voitures
ont quitté fleury en bière donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut s'attendre gros
embouteillages donc vers le centre de la
france par exemple en vain vers les
plages aussi bien l ouest qu au sud
effectivement d'ailleurs les principales
difficultés et des premières je dirais
que nous avons enregistrées c'est sur la
route de la côte d'azur c'est d'abord
dans le morvan où la circulation a été
perturbée toute la nuit
suite à un accident de poids lourd dans
la région de sennecey le grand
un camion chargé d'acétone s'est
renversée sacré une perturbation énorme
qui n'est pas encore résolu un peu plus
tard dans la matinée on a vu on a
observé un premier bouchon à vienne qui
à l'heure actuelle est de l'ordre de 11
km sur nationale 86 à pont-saint-esprit
remoulins également de très grosses
difficultés sur la 113 à arles d'abord à
pézenas ensuite sur la nationale 9 à
salses au nord de perpignan
et ce qui tend à prouver que il ya un
très gros trafic en direction de
l'espagne
on peut faire les mêmes remarques je
crois ce qui concerne le sud ouest
aussi bien sur la nationale 10 où on a
eu des difficultés depuis le départ de
paris pratiquement jusqu'à hendaye
je citerai les principales au départ de
paris trappe pour l'autoroute du sud a
été bouché certain nombre d'heures dans
la matinée ensuite poitiers angoulême où
on a mis en place une déviation
la région de bordeaux où on a mis en
place également des itinéraires émeraude
sur la nationale 20 de très gros
problèmes d'abord à la proximité
immédiate de paris comme toujours mais
aussi à vierzon où une déviation a été
utilisée elle l'est toujours
argenton sur 3 sur la presque totalité
de l'itinéraire donc pendant je vous
coupe je pense que effectivement le
problème est le même sur toutes les
routes de vacances et la bretagne
dont vous allez nous parler mais peut-on
maintenant savoir quand ces routes vont
se dégager à peu près dans d'ici 24
heures d'ici 48 heures quand pourra-t-on
circuler à peu près normalement sur les
routes de france maintenant avec vous
c'est nous pensons que le trafic sera
sensiblement équivalent cet après midi à
cet égard je voudrais donner un conseil
c'est que nous avons mis sur pied le
ministère de l'equipement a mis sur pied
un certain nombre d'itinéraires et
mérode qui sont faits pour doubler des
axes principaux et la constatation que
nous avons fait ce matin c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas suffisamment utilisé
je voudrais les recommandé car ils sont
bien fléché il permet d'éviter de
nombreuses difficultés importantes
il offre un parcours touristique donc
agréable et ils sont toujours
compétitifs sur le plan du temps de
parcours et bien merci commandes ont
donc et vous avez entendu cette dernière
recommandation
je pense qu'il est vraiment beaucoup
plus sage de prendre une route
touristique de toute façon venir est
sûrement pas plus vite sur les grands
axes et bien ceux qui ne sont pas en
tout cas sur les routes dès qu'ils se
passionnent pour le sport ont eu fort à
faire ces dernières 24 heures avec le
tour de france bien sûr et rappelez-vous
hier cette fantastique victoire d'ali
max au ventoux mais il y avait aussi
d'autres disciplines
et parmi ces disciplines deux
championnats du monde en sports
équestres à la baule c'est maintenant un
gallois qui est sacré meilleur cavalier
du monde il prend la place laissée libre
par jonquères d'oriola et puis il y
avait hier soir en italie le championnat
du monde de boxe catégorie super légers
mais peut-on parler précisément d'un
championnat du monde après le scandale
provoqué par l'arbitré italien qui a
disqualifié vous allez le voir
maintenant et le voir et comment le
français rené roques
voici les dernières secondes de ce
championnat du monde rené roques à une
culotte à bandes blanches
arcari est le tenant du titre dans un
instant il va y avoir un corps à corps
regardez le bien il va arriver dans dix
secondes
je dois vous dire que vous le reverrez
au ralenti un petit peu plus tard mais
vous êtes aussi bien placé que nous
maintenant pour savoir s'il ya ou non
coup de tête
voilà c'est fait l'arbitré monsieur
martinelli qui n'a encore donné aucun
avertissement à rené roques
si ce n'est une légère remontée
ce au troisième et au cinquième round
pour box tête en avant remontrances qui
n'a rien à voir avec un avertissement
larbitre donc va dégager sa
responsabilité et demandé le médecin de
service
dans un instant larbitre va lever les
bras de bruno arcari il indique donc qu
ils disqualifient rené roques décision
scandaleuse s'il en est il est vrai que
le champion du monde et italiens
l'arbitré italien les deux juges
italiens toutes les précautions donc été
prise et de plus le match avait lieu à
lugano en italie ce n'est pas avec de
tels procédés que les dirigeants de la
boxe pourront attirer encore longtemps
du public
alors pourquoi rené roques at il accepté
tout simplement parce que c'était cela
ou rien une précision au moment de
l'arrêt voici au ralenti de la scène une
précision au moment de l'arrêt on peut
estimer carcarie mené d'un point coup de
tête ou non à vous de juger
voici david broom champion du monde
ils montrent ici maty brawn chacun des
quatre concurrents finalistes david
broom mancinelli smith et choc molle qui
termineront dans cet ordre ont montés
successivement les quatre chevaux
david bloom a réalisé trois sans faute
ils devaient totaliser 4 points dans le
dernier parcours avec donald rex
david broom fut troisième aux jeux
olympiques de rome en 1960
où
bah
ont terminé avec le sport maintenant je
rappelle que les coureurs du tour de
france se dirige vers mont pellier ce
qui d'ailleurs ne pas faciliter le
trafic son synthé route déjà
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure bien
surchargé et bien encombré par les
touristes et ceux qui veulent enfin se
reposer sur la plage pour la politique
internationale maintenant eh bien on
serait tenté de dire que les deux grands
conflits en cours que dans les deux
grands conflits en cours il n'y a pas
d'information nouvelle dans les deux cas
se poursuivent maintenant disons des
négociations discrètes ou des entretiens
privés pour le moyen-orient
russes et américains semblent chercher
un compromis paulin pour l'indochine
monsieur nixon a rencontré monsieur
tente à nouveau et le seul point à
surveiller pour ce week-end c'est
l'irlande une lionne du nord où l'on
attend on s'attend à de nouveaux earth
entre catholiques et protestants
à l'occasion de la fête nationale
malgré les drapeaux et les fanions qui
ornent depuis hier soir les quartiers
protestants les villes d'irlande du nord
sont tristes et calme pourtant tous les
travailleurs ont déposé leurs outils
pour 15 jours mais la plus grande
activité est centrée de part et d'autre
sur la défense des quartiers 7000
soldats sont à pied d'oeuvre belfast sur
un effectif total de onze mille hommes
de troupes et de 4000 policiers dans
plusieurs localités des murs des murs en
tôle ondulée qualifié par les autorités
de ligne de paix ont été édifié des
barricades également disposés par les
soldats britanniques permettent à ces
derniers de veiller sans arrêt tandis
que des patrouilles surveillent les
points chauds mais à belfast
on pense que ce serait un miracle si
rien de grave ne se passer d'ici mardi
je vous disais il ya quelques instants
que monsieur temps avait rencontré à
washington le président nixon il avait
abandonné pour un temps l'onu vous le
savez qui est occupée par le congrès
mondial de la jeune 600 jeunes se sont
rassemblés à l'onu non sans avoir hier
assez sérieusement conspué d'ailleurs
monsieur tente sur place emmanuel de la
taille nous pas
de ce congrès des jeunes pendant une
dizaine de jours ces 600 jeunes vont
essayer de s'accorder sur les grands
problèmes qui divisent les adultes la
paix mondiale l'enseignement le
développement l'homme et son milieu
j'espère leur a dit dans son discours
d'ouverture le secrétaire général 80 que
vous ferez preuve de plus de largeur
d'esprit que vos aînés cela dit devant
un parterre blasé des ambassadeurs d
état à l'onu
la convocation de cette conférence n'a
pas été facile il y à des jeunes de 120
pays
certains n'appartenant pas à l'onu pour
la première fois par exemple des
délégués de l'allemagne de l'est se
trouve sous le même toit que ceux de
l'allemagne de l'ouest
des délégués révolutionnaire du
mozambique et de l'angola ont fait fuir
les délégués portugais la chine
populaire la corée du nord et le vietnam
nord n'ont pas accepté de participer
mais d'une façon générale il y avait
d'autres problèmes
les gouvernements n'étaient pas très
chauds de financer une opération qui
aurait pu provoquer une sorte
d'internationale des jeunes
contestataires
autre problème également la
représentativité ces jeunes ont été
choisis à raison de 5 à 8 par délégation
par les gouvernements et les
organisations mondiales de jeunesse mais
finalement on arrive à retrouver un peu
la palette des orientations politiques
bien pour la france bien sûr c'est la
route qui n'est pas occupe en ce moment
l'actualité
bien entendu les accidents attention une
fois de plus peut-être qu'avec ses
embouteillages il y aura moins de
victimes
si ce n'est plus d'accidents procès
péricard maintenant et bien à aix en
provence l'avocat général a demandé une
peine de 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour arlette boulbès et 10 ans pour les
deux autres accusés de verdict doit être
rendu ce soir notre rubrique maintenant
quotidienne vie moderne nous amène à
aborder un sujet médical et social dit à
l'afp a récemment en corée
l'actualité a mis en évidence le drame
d'ailleurs ce drame des enfants
handicapés pour que ces enfants
s'intègrent dans la société
des éducateurs spécialisés s'occupent
bien sûr de leurs différents problèmes
et cette semaine confrontation à
versailles de ses éducateurs venu
du monde entier un reportage de
christiane de lacroix 49 nations
représentées à versailles au palais des
congrès qui a réuni les éducateurs de
jeunes inadapté pour leur septième
rencontre internationale qui sont en
fait ces éducateurs spécialisés qui ne
sont ni des enseignants ni des
travailleurs sociaux ni des thérapeutes
ni des animateurs de loisirs pourquoi
avez vous choisi ce métier plutôt qu'un
autre
eh bien je pense que on parle
effectivement beaucoup de vocations dans
ce métier là au départ et je pense
qu'effectivement pour connaître au
départ il ya certainement une attirance
pour le jeune à une stress de
compréhension une faculté de le
comprendre mais je crois que très
rapidement ça doit être dépassée pour ça
devienne une véritable profession au
même titre qu'un instituteur maintenu km
ça qui effectivement travail dans la
relation humaine mais qui ont fait une
profession
je m'intéresse spécialement le
caractériel délinquance plutôt troubles
du comportement j'essaye de leur donner
une formation professionnelle qui leur
permet de s'intégrer dans la société
c'est le but primordial je pense que
vous êtes une des plus jeunes
congressistes êtes syrienne je suis
cyrielle j'ai suivi l'école de beyrouth
l'éducateur parce que c'est la seule
école qui existent en moyen orient vous
allez rencontrer quelle sorte de
handicapés dans votre profession
alors ce serait des enfants qui ont des
troubles du comportement
provenant soit de la famille soit
durieux et vous pensez avoir des
résultats
oui je pense parce que chez nous les
femmes y sont très attachés à leurs
enfants ils veulent vraiment faire
quelque chose
des enfants on essaye de leur faire
prendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport à leurs propres problèmes de les
autonomiser malgré tout qu'ils puissent
accepter leur milieu même si celui-ci
cauberotte certaines difficultés
pluralité des rôles pour l'éducateur
spécialisé
sa tâche consiste d'une part à laisser
l'enfant libre dans ses travaux de
création tout en le guidant et d'autre
part à le diriger dans son instruction
wafabail et ça c'est un petit carré oui
effacé comment daniel savait comment
regarde bien et commence à retirer un
grand carré où elles sont et formes
rouges et mal tu crois pas trop mal
pascal a bon elles sont là les médecins
et ça ce sont des formes rouges et fès
oui tu as toutes vos formes regarde bien
il te remet ça ce sont de bons élèves
est ce que ce sont des élections le goût
de l'effort de la curiosité d'avant oui
ils sont très curieux à partir du moment
où on ne veut pas les forcer à prendre
j'attends qu'ils aient le besoin l'envié
d'apprendre et après ils ont le plaisir
d'apprendre deux enfants évoluent
rapidement et d'autres moins selon leurs
capacités d'évolution et selon aussi
millions bien dans le calisson dans
lesquelles vivent change aussi ici le
milieu ne change pas l'enfant change pas
non plus à versailles les éducateurs ont
pu comparer leurs moyens éducatifs et
les résultats je travaille strictement
avec des adolescents délinquants très
fortement récidiviste est ordinairement
très intelligent est ce qui vous est
arrivé d'avoir des résultats probants
nous avons à cette institution au québec
à peu près le tout le plus fort de
résultats au niveau de la non décisive
vous même madame à bordeaux vous êtes
occupé des jeunes délinquantes mieux
quelques années ces deux là quand vous
les avez suivi aujourd'hui ce sont des
femmes comme les autres
oui j'en connais un certain nombre qui
sont les jeune femme épanouie et
heureuse mère de famille est très
consciente des problèmes d'éducation
en quoi consiste à ce rôle dans le décor
pour ce rôle social et bien je crois que
l'éducateur d'être le médiateur entre
ces jeunes qui ont des difficultés et la
société telle qu'elle est et tel que
nous voulons la voir évoluer un métier
donc difficile mais un magnifique métier
que je métier d'éducateur spécial
vacances maintenant c'est le moment et
disons urbanisme et paysages en effet
jusqu'à présent l'un des meilleurs
arguments de la côte d'azur était de
dire chez nous on ne voit pas en bordure
de mer ces immeubles de 18 ou 20 étages
que l'on peut voir parfois l'étranger
sur les plages et cela dit on jeter un
coup d'oeil au delà les pires est
jusqu'à présent effectivement on pouvait
dire cela ne se passe pas chez nous mais
chez les voisins mais tous ceux qui ont
leurs habitudes sur la côte d'azur sont
de plus en plus inquiète en effet au
bord des routes semblent s'épanouir des
panneaux publicitaires annonçant la
construction d'ensemble du tout une
série d'ensembles immobiliers alors le
visage déjà bien assombri faut le
reconnaître de la côte d'azur dans ce
domaine risque de changer encore plus
rapidement et c'est la question que se
sont posée claude manuel et françois
garnier et ce à l'aide d'un exemple
célèbre saint tropez le succès
esthétique et financiers de quelques
réalisations à grand spectacle semble
monter à la tête de certains promoteurs
partout sur la côte on ne parle que
d'aménagements rationnelle de portes
ultra moderne on édifie des villages
typiques en quelques mois
bref on fabrique des vacances plaqué or
pour hlm de luxe tout cela comme si la
côte d'azur n'était encore qu'une vaste
plage déserte à aménager saint tropez
qui pourtant semblait avoir les moyens
de préserver ses paysages trop célèbre
des attaques de la pelle mécanique saint
tropez est menacé à son tour
à tel point que nous pouvons prendre ce
petit port du var comme l'exemple type
de ce phénomène général à saint tropez
aussi on parle de restructuration
grâce à un plan d'urbanisme très
ambitieux saint tropez et ses plages
risque fort de succomber à leur tour à
la rentabilité de pelote qui à quatre
kilomètres de long et qui à quelques 40
50 m de large et qui vraisemblablement
une des plus belles de la côte d'azur
sinon une des plus belles de france
il faut par conséquent que nous essayons
et là c'est encore un problème qui se
pose toujours d'une façon extrêmement
mesuré en sauvegardant les sites
il faut que nous nous efforcions
d'aménager cette plage de façon que les
touristes puissent venir et ses
touristes ce sont des clients en
puissance se concentrent hop et
saint-tropez ses 6000 habitants l'hiver
80 ou 100 milles dans la bousculade du
mois
le département du var va accueillir huit
cent mille personnes supplémentaires
dans quelques jours sur les plages on ne
sait plus où poser le doigt de pied
mais cela ne trouble pas les promoteurs
et milliers de logements nouveaux sont
prévus sur toute la côte d'azur
et c'est cette industrialisation aveugle
que redoute entre autres les défenseurs
d'un calme trop prévient de plus en plus
troublé une redoute en soit les
spéculateurs
par exemple c'est à dire c'est à dire
que les spéculateurs ne passe pas au
bonheur des gens du pays mais à remplir
ses coffres organiser le loisir d autres
au détriment des habitants du pays sans
toucher à la vieille ville sans toucher
à la presqu'île est le même ou tout au
moins dans des conditions parfaitement
raisonnable et étudier il faut essayer à
l'entrée de saint tropez de faire à
nouveau sans tromper si vous le voulez
en nouveau complexe n'est ce pas
urbaniser cette partie de l'ipo
également en ce qui concerne les
terrains qui se trouve au droit du
nouveau port terrain qui valent un prix
fou eh bien ces terrains ne doit pas
rester à usage uniquement de parking et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
envisageons de faire une complexe
immobilier qui enserre aura le nouveau
port et qui sera et j'insiste sur ce
point qui sera conçue dans le style de
l'ancien port de façon qu'il y ait une
solution parfaite de continuité
respecter les cycles et la tradition
cette phrase figure dans tous les
projets d'aménagement
et le moins que l'on puisse dire est que
les responsables de ces réalisations ont
interprété très librement la formule
de toulon à nice en passant par cannes
villefranche 26 associations et 30000
personnes viennent de ce groupe et un
comité de défense pour tenter d'empêcher
le front de mer de se transformer en un
mur de béton à saint tropez comme
ailleurs bien ce qu'ils connaissent à
tous les gars du pays les pêcheurs les
paysans à les cultivateurs fait nouveau
ne me connaissent pas je peux dire qu'à
l'unanimité
la population s'était insurgé contre le
côté force au lieu de ce plan pourquoi
c'est pas possible retrouver au ballon
depuis quand même outil d'un pipeline
qui devait voler mais qu'est ce qui vous
gêne le fait que beaucoup de gens
pourrait venir
et bien voilà maintenant il est temps de
prendre congé de vous mais auparavant je
vous rappelle la principale information
de ce journal le corps de monsieur fedis
gaillard a été retrouvé ce matin en fin
de matinée au large de l'île gers après
le naufrage de son yacht à vient à 20h
bien sûr nous retracerons pour vous la
carrière de monsieur félix gaillard
merci de nous avoir écoutés